the Joe Rogan experience thank you see
that couple what they did do you see
that today what that so Trump was
talking about Oh Angela - yes and then
one of them I don't want to say the name
wrong so whatever it I forget what it is
I'll tell you exactly what it is what is
it's it's medication they use on a koi
pond well to kill bacteria that's the
one that they took yes it's the same
name I think it's called chloroquine the
same name of it but the one for the koi
pond has been like a - and another
uh-huh yeah the same name without the -
is actually a medication it's a
medication for malaria for malaria
correct parently holds promise but they
took koi pond
they've fish tank medicine they took
poison yeah that they took poison that's
what they took and then they were like
he told us to take it yeah but he didn't
you know it's not and then they're like
we saw it in our cabinet you think you
have [ __ ] malaria meds we had it in
the shed
yeah we used to kill everything in the
koi pond and we figured hell Jed took it
and he's dead well the woman they were
talking to her and they said now it was
funny because the the reporter was
baiting her the reporter was like now
this is you saw President Trump say that
you should take that yeah they were
shown in a lot and so she said they were
shown in a lot um no it's a different
name - different name you [ __ ] yeah
this is the same beginning and you
pressed a guy's a pea I feel comfortable
saying this public PSA you probably
don't have the cure at home right now
yeah I feel comfortable with you saying
that yeah unless you just got back from
somewhere where you had to take
something for malaria
yeah maybe man maybe maybe you have it
yeah it's a different medication yeah
but people are blaming Trump for that
yeah it's just like this game of trying
to get clicks and blaming people for
like Trump did not tell people to drink
koi pond killer no no definitely didn't
do that he's been hilarious and this
well did you see that one lady we're
talking I was talking about this earlier
this is one lady
who
is getting she's an opportunity to talk
to Trump in a press conference and she
said did you hear that one of you're one
of the members of your cabinet referred
to it as the come flu you know saw that
yeah and he's like the what say that
again and she was come flu so he makes
her say it and then he goes who who said
it and well I heard someone of yeah you
heard yeah this is the one question you
have right to ask the president United
States during one of the biggest health
crisis is the world has ever known
yeah and you were mildly racist term is
what you want to check in on yeah I
think we're gonna stop to that they want
to call people out yeah he did a thing
yet he must have caught up though
because yesterday he he read a statement
that like I I love our Asian Americans
and well it's because he kept referring
to it as the Chinese I know I know
Chinese virus in here II scratched out
on his I saw it yeah wrote Chinese
coronavirus Chinese but that's people
have to understand it's also because
he's in fierce negotiations with China
over these trade sanctions there's a lot
more not and he's a combative dude yeah
he'll take you know any chance to if you
saw the same lady did it with Kellyanne
Conway mmm-hmm thing same question yeah
and and you know and there and she's
like I'm not gonna get into speculation
here about our gut you said you don't
know who said it you just you just heard
someone said it and then you know this
lady didn't know Kellyanne Conway's
husband's half-asian right so her kids
are quarter Asian she's like I'm sure
you know like you're not saying that I'm
racist towards Asian my children are
Asian yeah like what are you what are
you doing isn't that marriage kind of
interesting oh yeah he's hilarious I
mean he's the most outspoken critic he
hates Trump beyond hates beyond hates
him and she's his most ardent defender
yeah it's crazy you guys go to bed at
night some people can these some people
can be like liberals and Republicans and
live together fine some people can be
like hunters and deviants and lived in
boats so vocal
emotions don't understand how to anyway
what do you want to eat like it's
[ __ ] crazy by the way how great would
it have been if Trump or Kellyanne come
we had been asked about the kung-fu and
they were like are you gonna say this
you're gonna say it's not a funny term
yeah it would be great it would be kind
of great I mean look if it was an
Italian virus yeah and then they call it
the pasta virus yeah I mean would people
who really get mad now
probably not would they go up the
meatball what would be the thing ya know
the pizza virus I don't know yeah
rigatoni virus parpadelle a virus it's
just I don't know man I've read a
terrible thing that one lady said um
that some lady she's Asian and she was
at a store and some lady yelled she had
a mask on shield [ __ ] you at her
interface and then she took off her mask
and coughed at her eye at the Asian lady
yeah coughed at her and yelled [ __ ] you
at her see that's when all the racial
jokes stop being yeah they all just went
out the window right there yeah cuz
there are religions out there but blame
an Asian American yeah person of Asian
descent living in America that has a
zero to do with any of this and she'll
be like [ __ ] you because there's people
just looking for an excuse to blame
whatever on someone else and if it's an
Asian person or a Latino person or
whatever the [ __ ] it is or all the
[ __ ] posts you ignore post 9/11 all
these poor Sikh PS I'm not yeah it's bad
enough that you're doing that but I'm
not even the target yeah usually you're
trying to reach here think turbans
everyone with the turban is Muslim
because we forget like you know the
world's full of idiots too
those are the people you really got to
worry about it's you know I don't want
people to die from this disease of
course but I would like us to lose a
significant portion of our [ __ ]
population
it'd be cool if it taught if it like
preyed on low IQ individuals all these
dummies trying not just low IQ because
there's some low IQ people that are
really nice but it would be great if it
was low IQ people who are mean like you
a disease that only killed racists just
like open Wow
mouth breathing people huh something
about racism just it just kills people
with racism like there's a gene and it
targets that gene and people are racist
they just drop like flowers there are a
lot of older people dying so it might be
working
it's definitely killed a few races in
this last few weeks
imagine if that's like something that
people focus on here's one silver line
[Applause]
these held grand Wizards are gone we
went into the Facebook pages of all the
people who died and 64 percent were
racist that'd be awesome
that would be a nice silver lining yeah
but what about the other you know no I'm
36 yeah it wasn't just nice old grannies
it's terrible but I love their neighbors
it's terrible yeah yeah but this is one
of those things where you can't even
crack a joke because then people quote
yeah yeah what about this person and
that person
[Applause]